do you think teachers should almost do
like one-on-one
you know
little johnny i believe in you kind of
thing like yeah that energy of like
turns out it's really important there's
um a study that was done it was actually
done in high school english classrooms
where all kids
wrote an essay for their teacher
and this was done as an experiment
half of the kids got feedback from their
teacher diagnostic feedback which is
great but for half of the kids it said
an extra sentence at the bottom that the
researchers had put on
and the kids who read that extra
sentence did significantly better in
english a whole year later the only
change was this one sentence what are
the sentences so what did the sentence
say the sentence said i'm giving you
this feedback because i believe in you
and the kids who read that did better a
year later
yeah
so
when i share this with teachers i say
you know i'm not suggesting you put on
the bottom of all kids work and giving
this feedback i believe in you
one of the teachers said to me we don't
put it on a stamp i said no
don't put it on a stamp
it's um
but
your words are really important and
kids are sitting in classrooms all the
time thinking
what does my teacher think of me does my
teacher think i can do this
um so it turns out it is really
important to be saying to kids i know
you can do this
and
those messages are not given enough by
teachers and really believe it and
believe it yeah it's like you can't just
say it you have to believe it
i i i sometimes cause like
it's such a funny dance because i'm such
a perfectionist i'm extremely
self-critical and i have one of students
come up to me and it's clear to me that
they're
not even close to good
and it's tempting for me to be like uh
to sort of give up on them mentally but
the reality is like if you look at many
great people throughout history they
sucked at some point yeah exactly and
and some of the greatest took non-linear
paths to where they sucked for long into
le into later life and so always kind of
believing that this person
can be great exactly
you have to communicate that plus the
fact that they have to work hard that's
it yeah
yeah and you're right silicon valley
where i live is filled with people who
are dropouts at school or who had
special needs who didn't succeed
um it's very interesting that have gone
on to do amazing work in creative ways
i mean i do think our school system is
set up to
value
good memorizers who can reproduce what a
teacher is showing them
and push away those creative deep
thinkers
often
slower thinkers they think slowly and
deeply and they often get the idea early
on that they can't be good at maths or
other subjects
so
um yeah i think many of those
people are the ones who go on and do
amazing things
so there's a guy
named eric weinstein i know many
mathematicians like this but he
he talks a lot about not having us
about having a non-standard way of
learning
i mean a lot of great mathematicians a
lot of great physicists are like that
and he felt like he became quickly he
got his phd at harvard became quickly an
outcast of the system like the
the education especially early education
system didn't help them
is there
ways for an education system to support
people like that is it this kind of
multi-dimensional learning that you're
measuring absolutely i mean i think our
education system still uses an approach
that was in classrooms hundreds of years
ago
the textbooks
have a lot to answer for
in producing this very uninspiring
mathematics
um but yeah if you open up the subject
and have people see and solve it in
different ways and value those different
ways somebody i appreciated a lot is a
mathematician called marion mizukani you
heard of her she
won the fields medal she was from iran
first woman in the world to win the
fields medal in mathematics she's she
died when she was 40 she was at stanford
but
her work was entirely visual
and
she talked about how her daughter
thought she was an artist because she
was always visualizing and
i attended she asked me to chair the phd
defense for one of her students
and i went to the defense in the math
department and it was so interesting
because
this young woman spent like two hours
sharing her work all of it was visual in
fact i don't think i saw any numbers at
all
it's awesome and
i remember that day thinking wow i could
have brought her like 13 year old into
this phd defense they would not
recognize this as maths
but when mary and ms kearney won the
fields medal all these other
mathematicians were saying that her work
had connected all these previously
unconnected areas of maths
and
so
but when she was she also shared that
when she was in school when she was
about 13 she was told that she couldn't
do maths
she was told that by her teacher is this
is iran
yeah
so i love that you know to be told you
can't be good at maths and then go on
and win the fields medal
is
cool
i've been told
by a lot of people in my life that i
can't do something i'm very definitely
non-standard
um but all it takes is that's that's why
people talk about like the one teacher
that changed everything exactly all it
takes is one teacher that's right that's
that's the power of that
so that that's like that should be
inspiring to teachers like i think it is
you as a single person given the
education system given the incentives
you have the power to truly change lives
in like 20 years from now that's right i
feel as a medalist will walk up to you
and and yeah thank you you did that for
me yeah absolutely and i share that with
teachers that even in this broken system
of what they have to do for districts
and textbooks
a single teacher can change kids maths
relationship or other subjects and
forever
you